I don't want to work I just wanna bang
on this muggle did you ask me here for
any specific reason I have it to you by
the beginning of next week all right
thank you very much
uh Phyllis Bracken Auto that's for
Donald Karen's bananas
tea bag bone Andrew hold on one second
you noticed a little bit of a mood shift
around here no I haven't noticed
anything really because I sat next to
Stanley for years and
this is nap time open eye nap time he
balances the phone on his shoulder and
just Powers down now look at him you got
to unleash the power of the pyramid
I can send you some email confirmation
you think it has something to do with
that incentive program oh 100 we all
want to see you tattoo your ass
I think people thought I was kidding
when I said that no you definitely
weren't kidding and that came across
loud and clear oh by the way I want to
run this in 120 points yeah it's a big
sale don't worry about though I don't
really care about the points I would
like a point receipt though hey yes this
is Jim Halper calling for Donald can you
hold on for one second thank you very
much who talked to Maggie at Kaufman
right and I'm back
how are you sir
I think you can squeeze a couple more
golf games in right there
Hey Kevin what are you doing don't talk
to me
right
Jim and I have different definitions of
friendship I think it's talking and
being friends and Jim thinks it's moving
to Connecticut and being best friends
with Josh well
phooey on that I uh
I'm done I'm not going to be speaking
with him anymore
whatevs long distance relationships
never work that is so true
ready mm-hmm
okay let me tell you what we're looking
for
sorry my medium ran late
really yes Jan really with the rep from
Hammer Mill they're exclusive with
staples used to be
Evan I'll call you in the morning to
work out the details we can now sell
Hammer Mill products
yes
well Michael I
I underestimated you yeah well maybe
next time you will estimate me
you know for our biggest discounts on 30
recycled and Ultra Premium laser okay
okay okay phone
yeah sure go ahead
let me talk to you about a few of the
other things we can offer namely we know
the tax season is coming up so by April
1st we can have you fully stocked the
discount prices on ink cartridges three
and also any forms that you're gonna
need seven you can custom make them
I appreciate what you guys are saying
but it makes more fiscal sense to go
with one of the big guys sure that's
true we can't compete with their prices
but let me ask you something how
important to you is customer service
one of the big guys been on hold this
whole time and this is Dunder Mifflin
hey Kelly it's Jim
here's my card
it's got my cell number my pager number
my home number and my other pager number
I never take vacations I never get sick
and I don't celebrate any major holidays
all right I get it we gotta do
all right right down the street
Kenneth Road born and raised spent my
whole life right here in Lackawanna
County and I do not intend on moving
I know this place I know how many
hospitals we have I have any schools we
have it's home you know
I know the challenges
counties up against here's the thing
about those discount suppliers they
don't care they come in they undercut
everything and they run us out of
business and then once we're all gone we
jack up the prices I don't know it's bad
it's terrible did it you know what it
really is
uh
I don't know
I guess I could give you guys a business
but you have to meet me halfway okay
because they're expecting me to make
cuts
corporate's gonna go ballistic but uh
you think we could Jan
play something more complicated if
you're like this is plenty complicated
so you played before I played it once or
twice with Jeff
it's Jeff Jeff was my mother's boyfriend
who she married
so her husband and your stepdad yeah
yeah I guess I never thought of it that
way though
you guys too much stuff together
yeah you know what he took me to a
baseball game once remember
it was weird though they took the
picture out of the game and I felt
really bad
because the pitcher wasn't going to be
able to play with his friends anymore
but Jeff said that the manager was
making a really good move by taking the
pitcher out he really respected the
manager
working
I'm doing it
it's really sad that your dog ran away
but wanted to keep you from going to the
park
I was afraid I would find him in the
park playing with another kid why I
guess that's why I thought I ran away in
the first place to find a kitty like
better dogs don't do that right why
would a dog do that I don't know when I
hear myself say it it just sounds
ridiculous but I never said it out loud
so
it's very important for you to be liked
isn't it well
let's not get too
this isn't a counseling session
okay
you son of a gun
under roof on this is Aaron okay let me
transfer you
why do you use your name when you answer
the phone oh that's how Pam does it I
just copy her she's she's sort of a
living legend
hmm
try it without using your name Dunder
Mifflin this is
oh yeah I like it Dunder Mifflin how may
I assist you
sis I sort of like the old way
just uh I just prefer without the name
and I thought okay no no no I got to
start doing some managing at some point
right I know I'm sorry but if it's not a
big deal we should just see the old one
and it really isn't okay good yeah okay
all right well I'd like to change it
actually well you know whatever
yeah whatever you think would work
what do you yeah I think a change would
be nice you could do the old way or the
you know whichever one you want to do
I'm so sorry
perfect so let me just get some basic
information from you
[Music]
sorry
um so sorry uh yes uh could you repeat
that
yes 10 Reams for the U.S District Court
did I happen to mention the 40 Reams for
The Battered Women's Shelter no
[Music]
stop it give me that give it
you see the board there's still an hour
this is illegal I don't care
all right